aber ich habe ein make magic dynamo das
für mich auch schon krass hast du schon
fertig gebaut bis behindert klar da wäre
ein schwerer fehler
ja ich halte dafür irgendwie 1000
fachleute was geht ab hier ist er gerade
zusammen mit konkreter hallo und dieser
per angeber ruhig ist jetzt dran
wir machen jetzt kenne ich bin und meine
alters und ich komme zu dir vielleicht
hat ja auch noch ein ende hat er nicht
8man cap pac-man paar sachen in eine
base wir klauen basinger basecap mann
wahllos mit der öffentlichen dienst
schon besser das zeige ich heute mal so
ganz oft hab ich das video gesehen was
mir geschickt hat es aber nicht gelegen
jetzt ein spanner gehört trat eine
falsche richtung
im sommer wird übrigens cool da wären
wahrscheinlich so ein zwei blocks von
muss zusammenkommen kleine videos
insgesamt im sommer wir kein entweder du
hier wir müssen ebenfalls regeln leute
wir fahren wohin wo es nur 3g gibt und
wir haben auch in den wohnungen kein
internet in deutschland natürlich habt
ihr da ihnen die idee wie wir da über
die zeit vor bolt sehen können
vernünftig ihrer hamborner hamburg
trainer tami hamburg nicht verwechseln
mit hans wurst den selbst der kleinste
kämen hier ist nicht ganz kurz in kürze
den taktischen smelter blut kleine
reimer funktioniert hier
so läuft das so ich glaube du brauchst
ein bisschen in wanne weil insgesamt 211
stück aber es zog er für jede single 2
in war aber der kef hat ihr die scooter
automat ich habe jetzt 15
soweit ferres brauchst du noch ich habe
15 in bar reicht das nicht dort ist lang
okay ich habe 15 war geht dann so weiter
was brauchst jetzt dass man kurz
überlegt du
braucht noch diese energie ist aber
diese relativ simpel mit einfachster
weise darauf gegeben hab mich mit
perfekt ich habe auch noch nicht aber
noch zwei in wachtberg mann stehen nein
doch auch im emmental posierten sie
artig ich kann mir die schlagen ist also
nicht braucht
du bleibst werk black line hat er
kräftig börse komplizierte sachen hier
du kannst einfach an eins von diesen
dingern ihr gehen hier rechts diese
mittel auch diese crafting stations die
funktionieren alle treffen tales
nikolaus und die sterbe oder vielleicht
so viel aber ich sehe was ihr lokal wo
ich louis du bist ne da bestellt kleine
fledermaus an i2 von diesen komischen
rollen an
ich liebe dich gar nicht laut trichet
ist irgendwas nicht getötet
bild läuft wie sein kleiner und
säbelzahntiger diesen super schnäppchen
alle video einfach kassierte mit einem
schlag
ich habe ja nichts es keine rüstung
weiter sprach ich habe zweieinhalb
herzen
ich stelle mir und ich passiere jedoch
ein halbes herz lasst mich in ruhe mag
es so dass ich die reflexionen helfen
bin bist du hier christel mehr was
draußen wartet mit rechtsklick also ich
kann mir selbst nicht mehr abbauen wenn
du nicht gibt und die kiste hat ihn
hitze hallo
weißt du was ihres lateins mit blut aus
der hölle gelöscht ich habe mich damit
gar nicht leisten ich hab ich schon so
aufgehört zu brennen kommen diese
scheiße gewitzte man die ich vergraben
ist es nicht meine ist stetig so dass
die afr einbauen oder so kate hält sich
freuen der wollte schon immer so eine in
der kreide basis herz mit meinen bauen
hier kannst du ihn regel dass man keine
platzieren soll
ich weiß nicht was sind regeln andere
wie wird das geschrieben so warten wir
brauchen jetzt okay ich brauche redstone
bericht komme ich mach das zuhause
fertig wir müssen diese komische staat
brauche ich auch noch dieser starb
larsson transmission colt ist auch
relativ leer ist auch saskia das geht
schnell so noch das mal zu hause fertig
was ist dann wenn ich dieses teil hab
dann brauchst du noch ein zweites teil
was relativ simpel ist bis auf ich
brauche noch so ein zweites ding ja da
hast du aber dann brauch ich ja noch
mehr info
dafür braucht sie keinen immer fürs
zweite brauchst du plastik schied aber
von denen habe ich welche kalkuhl
bekannt
ich fliege schon mal zu mir 'ich komme
kann man schauen ich suche schon die
sachen zusammen fürs zweite teil am main
zuschauer jetzt kein grund zur sorge ich
werde mich natürlich auch in den
nächsten folgen um mein eigenes
vorankommen kümmern
aber hier luca muss ein bisschen
vorproduzieren und
da haben wir natürlich gedacht ich hätte
ein bisschen besser liga who habe ich
mir auf jeden fall weiter ich muss mal
ganze 80 crafting station hat hier sogar
zugriff auf meine test rechts daneben
du hast du es auch kräftig station die
als market aufgefallen ich habe selber
eine mehr meint erst so alles so super
kompliziert war geöffnet
berlin aber käfer hat echt geile sachen
ich muss ich habe jetzt zum teil hinter
das echt immer wieder krass wenn leute
sowas heftiges braune also weil
irgendwie ich bin so der typ mir fällt
ein bisschen schwer es hohes gras zu
brauchen müssen weil ich habe ein make
magic dynamo das für mich auch schon
krass hast du schon fertig gebaut bis
behindert klar da werde ich schwerlich
heute dafür irgendwie 1000 franken an
bord das nicht schlecht
jetzt brauchst du allerdings place
powder bevor es richtig weiter gehen
kann war einmal alle sachen man einfach
von mir ja nicht verkehrt nicht nein ich
hatte das pech hatte dass ingrid hartges
gegangen und walter gepackt und jetzt
fertig steht eigentlich also was macht
ihr mit dass die frage ich habe schon
jetzt mal wieder zehn folgen ausholen
und hausbau
ich habe neue der pause gut gut viel zu
viel zu produktiv wieder so ich habe
schon mal hier was ja erst mal was ihr
so perplex
da brauchst du was ich hab dir was hat
ihnen packt das team dynamo und zwölf
stil brauchst gar nicht hier noch am
flügel brauchte dann später um weil das
ganze am besten schon machen bis es hier
erfahren mitten rein stellen das zeug
kannst du machen ja dann musst du
schauen wir hier unten dreht diese drei
flut aktien legen unten drunter durch
so und auf dieses teil wo ich jetzt
dieses mal blocking platz hier muss dann
später der loveparade aber der
solar-fabrik hätte ist das zweite
trainer und dann läuft muss oben drüber
noch so ein umbau oder so was man aber
es relativ simpel und dann hast du
eigentlich plastik schied gehen relativ
einfach mache man sich der preis liegt
ich hab glaub ich irgendwelche aber
darunter die so ein paar bäumen die
musste schnell abbauen und das packst du
diesen rubber einfach muss ich dir extra
ganz ganz schnell abbauen
sonst geht das leider macht dann bist du
okay okay krass von grad passt dann auf
am besten via besser ist es mal so denke
ich mir immer wieder wenn die alex die
augen nehme ich laufe einfach so ein
bullshit man sobald ich packe jetzt noch
ein bisschen hier von rainer baake rief
robert eppler
ich habe ich zwei extreme light trucks
komplett aus hass leistungsprofil baum
liga hat das unwetter ist manchen
unwetter am start
hier draußen wieso und weil du gesagt
hast grad voraus denn ich habe viele
recyclings rat bekommen ein kleiner
erfolg weil aus dem freibad links kann
ich dir die plastik schied machen und
die presse geschieht bist du am liedern
wie du vielleicht selbst weiß diesen
coup zu die plastik stets bin ich
wirklich anbieten wie viele taxis oder
vorproduzierte krass fiel viel zu viel
eine hohe zahl ich noch nie in meinem
leben gehört acht glaube ich alter acht
wie viel ist das ja für dich sind das 16
minuten
für mich sind das 24 stunden ein paar
alter schwede das ist echt krass
nirgendwo oder simon letztens einfach
mal so bei twitter bei mir dort gerade
zwei stunden darunter ist youtube echt
nicht mehr normal
ich sage jetzt erst mal paar tage links
hoch und sonne und ich so junge ich lade
jeden tag drei stunden ein video hoch
heute hat das verarbeiten bei mir so
lange wieder ordne das nur das war
richtig krass gut aber das ist echt cool
wenn du deine unendliche energie station
hat ist so weil das das funktioniert
alles viel schneller
ok also ich brate hier gerade in ravenna
dann erst den rohbau am braten
ich bin da kannst du direkt das macht
ihr direkt die plastik schied zum
marketplace trott und sowas habe ich gar
nicht mag mag ihm dafür brauchst du
dafür brauchst du ja das heißt dass
insgesamt vier place rat sammeln bei
makri machst du in dem du ein blaze
powder des kriegsherrn eben einfach eine
flatrate in das crafting fette snacks
partner mit diesem slime zeug davon hat
dirk ehlers welches halbjahr gegebene
dessen was redest du grad also okay das
hatte doch diese gelatine slums oder
sowas na ja die habe ich eher davon
musste welche mit black spider
zusammentun
ich habe keine blätter er da müssen
immer mal in die hölle vorbeischauen
also habe ich mein eigenes ja dann legt
los doch nicht behindert
irgendwie scheiße oder also wissen ob
die linke kandidiert
ich kann mich nicht umbringen in diesem
projekt ich habe hier unten auch schon
gewisse kiste eingesperrt alter ich wer
über die kisten eine kerze soll ich gehe
jetzt mal hier und einfach rein da muss
doch wohl irgendwo jetzt hier muss doch
eigentlich muss auf jeden fall ein wenig
fahrer schlug auf jeden fall musst du
eigentlich wer nicht ist das seien dann
musst du halt nicht ich drehe hier schon
mal diese plastik schied
verwaltungsdirektor obsidian mitbringen
ich habe noch drei oder ich brauche
5 also vielleicht eigentlich ich packe
ich packe direkt erzeugt so was du es
brauchst ich pack's sich die plastik
schied merkst du nicht dass du es
vergisst nicht was für eine show darf
nicht dass du da guck mal hier in die
kiste die dann links unten links sind
die plastik schiedsmann ist klar zwei
stück und ein absolvieren also nicht
dass du nicht dass sie die plastic
schied dann irgendwie ewig zusammen
kraft ist soja koopmann meine crafting
station
was ist da dass das was ich schon habe
hast du eine bis unten rpg ich nicht
aber ich habe es im café 90 mal ließ
geheilt junge wie wir uns einfach diese
waffen machen wollten uns einfach so
easy des todes ja nee ich hab ich hab
dir dein ding gebracht
so brauchen wir noch irgendwas wollte
ich glaub ich muss dann auf jeden fall
meine höhle dafür braucht obsidian und
dafür oder du gehst du einfach durch das
portal von themen was ungefähr zwei
sekunden vor dem aus steht
nur wussten dass zwei sekunden vor dem
haus direkt da unten am fuß vom berg
also der war zumindestens so oder links
rein geht ja hier werde durch diese tür
rein ist direkt links luca immerhin
direkt ich will ich weiß jetzt ich habe
die zeit jetzt denn wir sind schon
wieder am ende der folge ich bin jetzt
mal ganz kurz in einer höhle bei mir
lädt das jetzt schon einen kleinen
vorgeschmack was in der nächsten folge
abgehen wird weil dann hast du
eigentlich auch bald geschafft
unendliche energie ist schon 'ne geile
sache freunde ich bin in der höhle in
julia super danke auf jeden fall an dich
max haben da waren in der hölle müssen
wieder mein nächstes ziel ist dann auf
jeden fall dieser dings dieser dings
dieser lava verriet soll dann der
nächste machen danke dass du mich da so
ein bisschen auf die sprünge gebracht
hast gar keine ersten beiden folgen
bin ich dann eventuell alleine oder noch
mal mit mir
während wir morgen enormer aufnehmen
oder das am morgen zeit ja muss jetzt
hast du irgendwann bis 15 uhr habe ich
zeit morgen ich kann aber allerdings
noch nichts versprechen vielleicht müsst
ihr auf diesen supertollen kran
verzichten egal dann mal alleine
molekularkoch diese einen transmission
kohl habe ich ja schon mal gesagt haben
ich dir ein gut ab samstag gute folge
auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht für mich
selbst über produktiv aber dass sie auch
ein gemeinschaftsprojekt also es geht
nicht darum dass man jetzt hier so krass
auf sein eigenes vorankommen aus ist ich
fand es auch so cool gesagt schreib mal
beim sitzen luca vorbei und bis zur
nächsten folge dann meine ihr könnt die
folge auch wenn die form noch mal sehen
wollte noch mal bei max angucken kann ja
seht ihr genau das gleiche